bonjour brut alors je vais vous montrer
aujourd'hui comment on fait un autotest
qu'ovide alors ce test est composé de
différents éléments
vous avez la notice d'utilisation vous
allez avoir le tube dans lequel vous
allez mettre ce que vous avez prélevés
et le petit compte gouttes sur le dessus
du tube vous avez la cassette sur lequel
vous allez déposer ce que vous aller
prélever au niveau du nez et le fameux
écouvillon avec lequel vous allez faire
le prélèvement alors ce que vous faites
avant de commencer bien évidemment s'ils
se laver les mains avec l'eau du savon
ou de la solution hydroalcoolique
ensuite vous commencez par ouvrir le
tube vous ouvrez votre votre et
couvrions ce qui est important avec ces
tests là c'est le prélèvement alors le
prélèvement c'est vraiment un serrer les
coûts villon entre 2 et 4 cm donc
c'était qui vont alors là c'est pas très
impressionnant et ça va pas très loin
contrairement aux prélèvements que l'on
fait pour les tests antigénique et celui
ci donc voilà il pas chatouiller la
qualité de la narine sinon le
prélèvement ne sera pas bon et tourné à
peu près une quinzaine de secondes dans
chacune des narines
alors pour prélever voilà je le mets
alain perpendiculaire s'est introduit
les courions se tourne 5 6 fois à
l'intérieur ça peut faire larmoyer un
tout petit peu voilà et je recommence de
l'autre côté attention de ne pas aller
trop loin et de ne pas diriger
l'écouvillon vers le haut une fois que
le prélèvement a été fait vous le mettez
à l'intérieur du tube
mais de manière générale c'est une
minute en contact avec le liquide qui à
l'intérieur du tube alors il faut bien
pressé quand vous avez terminé vous
pouvez le jetez vous vous mettez le
compte gouttes dessus donc faut bien le
fixe et pour être sûr que lorsque vous
allez retourner et pressé le liquide ne
va pas sortir à l'extérieur
le deuxième point important à respecter
c'est le nombre de buts que vous allez
devoir mettre au niveau du puits
puisqu'en fonction des tests il y aura
un nombre
variable celui-ci ces quatre gouttes je
dépose mes quatre gouttes faut pas
appuyer trop fort pour ne pas faire tout
tomber non plus et expulsé le petit
compte-gouttes donc j'en ai une deux
trois quatre
une fois que les quatre gouttes sont
posés on attend 15 minutes que le
liquide migrent tout le long alors on va
dire le résultat le petit moment de
stress et bah ça y est c'est négatif
comme on peut le voir ici donc c'est bon
je suis rassuré alors comment est ce que
je vois que les guette alors on le voit
parce que comme je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure au niveau du thé il y a aucune
barre qui apparaît quand on a un test
positif on voit bien apparaître
justement donc au niveau du thé une
barre
alors de ces tests positifs on essaye de
ne pas le jeter n'importe où de le
mettre potentiellement dans le sachet
qui est fourni avec certains tests et si
vous avez un doute
comme je le disais ne pas hésiter à voir
avec votre pharmacien pour savoir s'il
ya une prise en charge particulière